The new tools we learned in
this session, loops, arrays,
hashes, are some of the most important
concepts in all of programing.
We'll continue to build upon
them as this course progresses.
Everything we've done so far has been
with relatively simplistic data,
an array of names,
a hash representing a person.
Those types of examples are important,
when you're starting out, but
they may seem a little bit trivial.
It's time for us to step it up.
In this session,
you're going to build a project
using more complex, realistic data.
Imagine, that we run an online retailer,
Toy City, that sells the best
toys in all the world.
You love your job, except for one thing.
Things are not going well for Toy City.
Children actually hate
toys now with a passion.
To help turn the business around,
our boss has
asked us to write an application that
will analyze our product sales data and
generate a nice looking sales report.
Here's a preview of the crazy product
sales data we'll be working with.
We'll revisit this project and continue
to improve it in future sessions.
In this first iteration, we're going to
focus on running some simple analysis
on the data and printing
a simple report to the terminal.
In future iterations,
we'll save the output to a text file and
incorporate an API.
This project is a big step up,
but don't worry.
We'll be here to help you along the way.
Let's go ahead and take a closer look at
the project specifications and setup.